bonjour monsieur landry bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté de notre invitation on
va parler de votre nouveau film microbes
et gasoil qui sort le 8 juillet et qui a
été tourné en partie à versailles ville
de votre enfance ce faisant c'est exact
bon jusque là tout va bien
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un film
autobiographique c'est l'histoire de
deux jeunes garçons ils encourent à 14
ans au moins 14 15 14 15
une paire d'amis oui qui deviennent amis
finalement parce qu'ils sont un peu tous
les deux un peu différent voyez sera pas
différent des autres là bas ça se passe
à faire ça effectivement
donc j'ai grandi à versailles et
1 j'ai commencé à regrouper des
souvenirs pour écrire ce film j'ai loupé
des souvenirs d'amitié que j'avais à
chaque fois je me retrouvais ami avec le
gars le plus exclus de la classe mais
quand je cherchais à comprendre pourquoi
et en
et on réfléchit ça ça j'ai un petit peu
j'ai développé l'histoire qui étaient
les missions de la mission du regard un
peu livrés à eux-mêmes finalement oui un
peu style un peu mur aussi pour leur âge
ils sont venus ils sont parce que les
sons ils sont pas influencés par le
groupe et sur eux-mêmes mallardo pour
saluera certainement une maturité
voilà et alors au niveau du du temps
finalement vous dit que vous vouliez pas
bloquer sa dans les années soixante dix
il n'y a pas spécialement d'éléments
typiques des années 70 c'est un peu ça
pour être maintenant c'est maintenant je
transpose et et des souvenirs qu'il a
existé d'événements quand il existait
dans les années soixante dix mais je
voulais pas faire un film sur les
esprits on dise ça m'intéressait pas
parce que ça aurait été de parler de lui
décrire une époque et moi je voulais
parler d'une amitié donc j'ai j'ai
actualisé les choses puis finalement
comme ils sont un peu à l'écart anti
mode ça permet de comprendre le fait
qu'il s'exprime d'une manière un peu
différente au fait qu'ils aient pas
accès certaines technologies on-line pas
très connectée n'en sont pas de
connecteur ouais ils sont encore pleins
de rêves et ils sont très bricoleur on
voit bien que tu es déjà largement
d'écran grands noms les âmes fabriquer
des choses qui existent qui reste pas
virtuelle
voilà c'est dans le concret alors pour
en revenir à la leur façon de parler
ça dépend qui paraît un peu suranné
parfois dans la bouche d'un ado de 14
ans finalement c'est un tout votre façon
de parler avoue j'ai l'impression oui je
pense j'ai déjà repris mais de la même
manière que je m'exprimerai quand
j'avais leur âge et encore maintenant un
peu de choses près et simuler
réfléchissent à ce qu'ils disent donc il
il utilise pas langage instinctif et ne
jure pas et puis à théo 15 une sorte de
philosophe
parce que du fait de sa projection il ya
beaucoup de temps pour pour pour lire
pour ce pour se nourrir il est très
cultivé et et corrige daniel quand
daniel devient ainsi un petit peu trop
vulgaire un peu trop dans la norme
voilà finalement et et s'est attiré
globe ce que vous même et d expression
que j'ai vu dans le dossier de presse
quand vous dites j'ai vu sa petite tête
j'étais dans tous mes états afin d
expression je trouve qu'ils sont plus
tellement employé en annonçant que c'est
vous qui parlez à travers eux quoi s'est
dit j'ai vu ce petit nom vous vous dites
qu'en campanie ring avec toi il avait
laissé sa petite tête ou après après
avoir tourné l'écumé des jours vous dit
j'étais dans tous mes états mais dont
parle pas comme ça ben ma grand-mère
soit que la chasse aux médailles petit
mot à dire j'étais un chef non mais dans
tous mes états ça veut dire autre chose
plus intéressant il y avait chez
j'essaye de parler de manière ça pour
exprimer les choses de manière la plus
précise possible mais je pense que c'est
ce que font les gamins les utilise pas
des mots extraordinaire parce que ces
mots là je les connais pas bon à un
moment donné il expliqué
mon panache eric parce que je me
souviens comme l'a expliqué un jour je
ne connaissais pas et puis j'ai je me
souviens de ce copain ou plusieurs de
ses copains qui avaient une connaissance
assez poussée du vocabulaire et ça
m'impressionnait d'accord et vous dites
là vous avez tourné avec une petite
équipe il y avait une seule caméra
oui ça c'était important pour moi de
recentrer le tournage et surtout de me
focaliser sur l'histoire et surtout sur
les percées sur le sentiment des
personnages
oui ça m'a beaucoup plu de travailler
comme ça c'était une petite équipe dans
un esprit de famille est vraiment on
était concentré sur tout le monde est
conscient que ce qui se passait devant
la caméra l'avait pas un million
d'actions qui se passait derrière qui
déconcentre tout le monde est là vous
n'êtes pas dans tous les états membres
lire les noms les moins de pression non
j'étais très détendu très détaillé et on
a besoin de fait toujours apple à la
frontière de l'enfant soit leur force
nous habite
comment dire coup d un autre âge dans
votre tête
comprenez moi oui oui oui c'est très
difficile pour moi avec cette image que
je sais quel âge a votre tête
moi j'ai 17 ans ça peut vous rassurer je
sais pas moi moi je pense que j'ai 14
ans je sais rien c'est impossible à dire
mais on s'aperçoit que les angoisses
qu'on a un stage la haye les problèmes
qui se posent à nous finalement ils
restent les mêmes j'étais justement en
train de penser que j'avais les
angoisses de mort à cet âge là et que
finalement la seule chose qui me fait ne
pas trop y penser c'est d'autres
problèmes qui se rajoute à des problèmes
plus faciles à résoudre
non pas forcément et occupe une bonne
partie de ma tête
bon en parlant de votre tête la vie avec
les rêves comment comment vous vivez
avec vos rêves on a besoin c'est
qu'après trop de frontières c'est que
c'est très commode hier ça a investi
votre vie votre journée oui je pense que
c'est un petit peu le cas de tout le
monde je pense que souvent il ya pas mal
de gens qui se souviennent pas du tout
de leur rêve
oui mais je pense que même ces personnes
peuvent se révéler dans un état d'esprit
assez triste assez
déprimé et c'est parfois tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont fait un rêve triste
mais s'en souviendra en tout cas moi ils
sont heureux vous en souvenez moi je me
souviens je rêvais de telle ou telle
histoire qui m'était arrivé il ya 15 ans
j'en ai une profonde nostalgie je me
réveille je suis triste quand même de
pleurer au réveil parce que je
m'aperçois que la réalité dans laquelle
j'étais n était pas ce n'est pas la
réalité mais était souvenir la réf
et est-ce que vous utilisez dans votre
travail justement dans ce film là est-ce
que vous avez vous êtes servi de rêve
que vous aviez fait pour pour alimenter
cette histoire en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que pendant que j'écrivais
la première par la première moitié du
film qui était complètement
autobiographique jusqu'au départ du
voyage
je faisais des rêves qui m'ont guidé
pour la deuxième partie du film pour le
voyage pour leur aventure qui sont donné
des idées de péripéties voilà c'est des
péripéties que j'ai vécu un rêve pas
tout
une peut-être la moitié ça m'a guidé oui
c'est assez pratique c'est bien tombé
et justement me faudrait peut-être
préciser donc ils sont 2 microbes gasoil
microbes alors c'est vous voulez pas
dire voilà aygadoux elle s'est condensée
donc de différents amis et ils décident
de défoncer le futur resté trois ans et
de partir avec une maison qu'on voit
d'ailleurs derrière le construite même
et partirait de pousser jusqu'à jusqu'où
ils poussent jusqu'à au début ils
veulent pousser qu'un amoureux là ils
veulent avec un but sens voilà en fait
bientôt ficelles ses dérivés dont
l'ancien colo de théo et puis finalement
il ya un vide secret c'est que daniel et
il a gardé l'adresse internet de laura
glamour
et il influence très haut pour le moment
on est dans le morvan car les pentes
sont plus douces pour les soi disant
c'est un enjeu bien et ils ont une
expression que je trouve très très
rigolote qui disent ils veulent acquérir
une indépendance absolue s'évader d'un
contexte merdique dans lequel il est
impossible de s'épanouir
car ils sont sous-évaluées ouais c'est
le syndrome des enfants fréquentent
finalement non j'avoue que je serai à
prague elle n'est pas du tout réaliste
par rapport à l'âge mais elle m'a fait
et on est très élevée on évolue dans un
contexte merdique c'est lui moi ça me
fait rire oui si ça fait rire c'est pas
la manière dont effectivement ils
parleraient mais en même temps ils ne
ressentent comme ça bien sûr et c'est
justement de ce que peuvent ressentir
des enfants à l'école qui se sentent un
peu plus mûr que que les autres qui sont
qu' un décalage et qu' ils rentrent pas
dans le moule et que eux il pourrait
s'épanouir en faisant en construisant
une maison et pas en apprenant la table
2008 et enfin je pense que ça n'est pas
tant que ça marche a un peu à tous les
arbres c'est à dire que on peut très
bien dire n'importe quel âge que l'on
est sous-évalué que si on était
appréciée à sa juste valeur
on pourrait s'épanouir plus celle que
quand on est enfant les coincer le
contexte on ne choisit pas après en
grandissant on est malheureusement quand
on est enfant on est le plus coincé on a
un peu plus de choix adultes mais
et choisit cinéma pour vous ai pas dit
je suis un cas un petit peu chanceux on
va dire oui vous êtes d'année moyens
peut-être je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
chance aussi
ok voilà après je me demandais vous
n'êtes pas qu'il y ait un moment vivre à
l'étranger bon là est pourquoi vous êtes
parti à part le côté professionnel vous
aviez envie de vous éloigner de la
france 2 de prendre du recul non le ct
professionnel c'est dire que j'ai
commencé à faire des clips en angleterre
puis aux etats unis et ont donné à la
fin des années 90 jeu au début des
années 2000 je me suis dit j'ai envie de
faire un film et je me suis installé à
los angeles
c'est même là que j'ai appris à conduire
j'étais juste à côté du signe hollywood
et j'ai cherché des taux continue en
faisant à faire des clips
j'ai cherché des projets de films j'ai
lu des scénarios ça a pris beaucoup de
temps que finalement j'ai fait mon
premier film nature et puis après j'ai
envoyé sur terre et sunshine et là ça
m'a emmené à new york
je suis resté parce qu'une dizaine
d'années à new york à carnoux et c'est
juste je suis un petit peu les films
d'accord et est-ce qu'il y aura un avant
et un après pour vous après ce film ça
libère quelque chose d'avoir parlé son
enfance de son adolescence
oui c'est j'en parle je parle un petit
peu de mes sentiments mais c'est vrai
que là c'est vraiment à propos de mon
enfance c'est difficile de savoir s'il y
aura un avant et un après ce qui était
important pour moi aussi c'était de
films et de cette manière beaucoup plus
sobre et un peut-être que j'aurais envie
de continuer à travailler comme ça et
est-ce qu'il y aura la suite ils
croivent et gasoil à 18 ans aux dépens
de mercredi conçu par ailleurs à la
suite s'il pleut un crédit ou s'il fait
une canicule
tout se jouerait que mercredi que la
même non rassurez moi une question
subsidiaire je comprends pas pourquoi il
s'appelle daniel je vais envoie moi je
vous rappelle lucien il fallait un nom
qui puisse marcher comme un nom fille
oui l'écran se confondre et puis j'avais
un voisin qui s'appelle daniel guéret
réalité de la rue d'après l'oms
oui mais à daniel c'est pas un prénom
très bonne nouvelle mary cohr géant
français comme ça et donc ça c est
ressorti cette histoire de
qu'on vous prenez souvent pour une fille
oui c'était la vérité c'était un peu
pénible parfois mais en même temps
j'avais pas envie de me fondre dans la
masse jean-louis garder ma particularité
au point de souffrir du fait qu'on
prenait pour une fille que tout plutôt
que d'avoir les cheveux courts comme les
fils de bourgeois était prévu comme ça a
changé ma fille un peu ça va changer un
petit peu mais quand même quelque chose
mais encore heureux
je rigole bon ben écoute et un grand
merci michel ben merci pour ce beau film
et prenez envie de voir et revoir et qui
est super bon alors super super super
ont verdi 1